[Music]
in
1916 this is year after einstein
wrote his paper on the general theory of
relativity
einstein continued to think about the
theoretical
ideas and he wrote a paper
which we have here where he was
thinking about the possibility that if
space
and time can warp and curve
then it might be the case that space and
time can also
ripple right the image to have in mind
is think of a trampoline
right a trampoline you put something
heavy in the middle has a nice curvature
to it
but if you have kids that are jumping
all around on the trampoline the shape
doesn't stay nice and static
it ripples it vibrates so he was
wondering whether it might be the case
that space itself might be able to
undergo
these kinds of ripples these kinds of
vibrations
and this would be known as a
gravitational wave
now interestingly he wrote a first paper
in 1916 in 1918
he corrected an error in the 1916 paper
and he continued to struggle
with whether or not he actually believed
that gravitational waves were a
prediction
of the general theory of relativity and
he worked on this
by himself he worked on it with
collaborators
nathan rosen being one of them and a
couple years after this paper where they
expressed some confidence that
gravitational waves were real
rosen writes another paper where he
basically says that he thinks they're
all
just a mathematical artifact and
i think many historians think that
einstein himself kind of had that view
that there really weren't these ripples
in the fabric
of space and yet by the 1960s when the
mathematical methods had been refined
where we could really look at einstein's
equations
and extract from them the actual
physical predictions with
certainty it became clear that
gravitational waves were
a prediction of einstein's theory which
would mean
that if you had say two objects like two
neutron stars
rotating around they would so disturb
the environment that they'd send out
this
train of gravitational waves and that
would mean in principle
you could detect these because
downstream
if you're in the wake of one of these
gravitational waves
you will experience this kind of an
effect
a stretching and a squeezing a
stretching and
a squeezing now i should say
this animation is not to scale
when you actually do the calculation you
find that for a typical
astrophysical phenomenon you'd find that
the stretching and squeezing would be
less than an atomic diameter
so the question is how could you ever
measure something so fine and yet
as we'll discuss now exactly that kind
of
a measurement has been achieved and so
to talk about that
let's turn to our
next guest to take a closer look at
gravitational waves as the lead
astrophysicist in the ligo scientific
collaboration
she is a distinguished professor of
physics and astronomy at northwestern
please join me in welcoming vicki
calaguera
so thank you for being here thank you
and
we'd like to get some insight into how
gravitational waves have been detected
and
ligo is the facility so what does ligo
stand for
ligo is a double acronym actually it
stands for
laser interferometer gravitational wave
observatory and laser itself is an
acronym
so it's a double acronym and what's that
acronym i didn't think i was going to
ask you that
laser is such ingrained in my head i
don't remember the full acronym
i think it's light amplification by
stimulated emission of radiation but i'm
not sure
i'm not sure
okay so here's our detector here's our
gravitational wave telescope
it's a new type of telescope it doesn't
look like your traditional telescope
does it
so it has this corner station where you
can see it there
and and then it has these tubes
and it's like tubes of a regular
telescope except
these are on the ground and there are
two of them and from the corner station
we shoot down
lasers in at right angle and they travel
down these four kilometer tubes vacuum
tubes
and they reach the end they bounce off
mirrors and they come back
and they we study the light the laser
light that comes together
and through the interference pattern of
the laser light we can tell
whether the mirrors at the end of those
arms are being
shaken in this squeezed and stretched
squeeze and stretch motion
that gravitational waves are supposed to
um
affect uh space and time but space is
what we can think about
easier and you can actually measure
shaking
by atomic distances
in fact it's even smaller than that it's
it's a
smaller than one thousandth
of the nucleus
on the scale of the four kilometers it's
the most
accurate measurement we have ever
achieved humans have ever achieved
anywhere in any field of science or an
engineering now how do you know that the
shaking
is a gravitational wave and like not
someone just kicking the equipment
there's a lot of shaking going on uh
everywhere and that was the reason why
we didn't just build one of these
detectors we built two detectors one
in louisiana state and one in washington
really far away from one another
because if the shaking is happening uh
and it's affecting the uh one detector
and it's coincident
i'm sorry and it is earth-based then
it's very hard to reproduce the exact
kind of shaking the exact kind of
squeezing and stretching
and have it happen in two different
locations independent locations
so far away so having coincidence
as we call it at the same time with
exactly the same
squeezing and stretching pattern it was
extremely important so we really needed
to be able to claim such a an
unprecedented claim that we detected
gravitational waves
it was really important to have
observations of the exact
same signal at the same time in two
different independent locations
and this in this first happened this was
the first achieved in twenty fifteen
well the world didn't know on september
14
2015. some of us did some of us did
um and that was a life-changing day
for the hundreds of scientists and
engineers who are members of the ligo
scientific collaboration
the world found out on february 11th
uh 2016 when we made the first
announcement announcement
and and so what was found so what was
found is uh
that basically two black holes
one uh in orbit around the other uh
were disturbing space-time uh not very
close to us
uh not at the center of our galaxy but
actually
over a billion light years away
at some other galaxy and the two black
holes were
coming together because of the emission
of gravitational waves they were
disturbing space time around them
generating these ripples that you talked
about earlier
and and these ripples were traveling for
over over a billion
uh years at the speed of light and on
september 14
they came approach the earth from the
south they hit
our louisiana detector first and seven
about seven milliseconds later they hit
our washington
uh state detector second and that's what
you expect because that's how long it
would take light to travel
that exactly so there has to be a finite
delay because of course gravitational
waves just like light
doesn't travel instantaneous it takes
instantaneously it takes time
so the two black holes as they were
coming together in their orbit losing
energy because of gravitational wave
emission
at the end they emerged like in this
other movie as well
they emerged and they i'll explain the
sound in a minute
because it's not self-explanatory not
really
not everybody gets it well i i did a
version of this
on on on stephen colbert's show and his
interpretation is
god bugs bunny that that's how he uh
that's his interpretation i should say
stephen colbert is a northwestern
undergraduate well look at that
i i've met stephen
uh and we have talked about the
gravitational wave discovery
so so the two black holes are coming
together and eventually they have
nowhere to go they're coming and
they're basically physically touching
except there is no
actual surface there is no hard surface
there is that imaginary surface where
light can't escape
and the two black holes merge into a
single bigger black hole
they form a single black hole and then
that single
bigger black hole settles and
the disturbance stops and the
gravitational wave signal
stops so it's a finite transient signal
there is this whole turmoil in space
time
and by the time you form the single
single black hole
the whole thing ends now we talk about
the actual signature
as shaking these devices in washington
and louisiana
by less than an atomic diameter yes but
what
was that signal like when the black
holes actually collided
way out there a billion light years away
um
i don't have that particular number for
you
but it does scale as one over the
distance
so if we take 1.3 for that first
detection if you take
1.3 billion light years
away it was that many
times bigger when it was
generated so i'm calculating yes so that
would be about
50 times the energy output of every star
in the observable universe yes if i
divide by energy
yes yes yes i'm very quick yeah
yeah uh so so that's so so the basic
lesson though is
it's a huge it's a huge explosion of
gravitational wave energy
for a very small amount of time so the
signal was 0.2 seconds
uh and for that two seconds when it uh
that lasted within
our uh the frequency range uh that
ligo the ligo detectors are sensitive to
so
you should think uh you heard uh um
about electromagnetic waves and they
come in different
uh frequencies our optical is the
optical frequency range
infrared radio waves etc
uh these are all different frequencies
of the same type of wave electromagnetic
waves
gravitational waves have frequencies
themselves
so ligo can't see every single
gravitational wave out there
can only see frequencies between about
20
hertz to about now
uh maybe uh hundreds of hertz let's say
700 of hertz at best right
so in that frequency range this first
binary black hole collision lasted about
0.2 seconds right in that short amount
of time
the collision and energy generated
in gravitational waves outshined by a
factor of 50
all the light generated by
all the stars in the whole visible
universe
not visible by eye but in the whole
universe that we know
of and we could ever detect and it just
dilutes
as it travels it does right yes so so
you know i i i've you know been asked
about this is such an amazing discovery
that you and your team i mean it's just
it's fantastic but how well actually can
we look at the data because then i want
to ask you a question can you bring up
can you raise the volumes i can't really
hear it
so that's the tiny signature
so you can just hold it up there if you
would so here's here's mine there's a
few things to talk about
please go ahead well my general question
is
how can that that little tiny window of
data
give you so much insight into what the
source was yeah
the reason is that this scribble that we
can see on the screen
uh and the banana that you can see on
the screen carries a lot of
information okay uh and i'll i'll
i'll take a a few uh you know maybe a
minute or two to explain it
first let me start by explaining the
significance of the sound
okay i don't want anybody in this room
to have any misunderstanding
gravitational waves are not sound waves
okay so don't go away telling anybody
that gravitational waves are sound waves
however we can take the frequencies
remember i said something about
20 hertz to a few hundred hertz if you
know something about music and the
frequency of
sounds that our ear is sensitive to
that's about the range
of the frequencies of sound that our ear
is sensitive to
so we can take the gravitational wave
frequencies
and pretend it's a sound it's not a
sound but pretend it's a sound
and convert it into sound and say
what would the gravitational wave sound
like if it were a sound and this is what
it sounds like
it sounds like a bird's chirp
whoop which is not quite what you heard
but that's how it came out my mouth but
cassie one question on that
one question that so so it's laudable to
be clear
on that but just to also because if our
eardrums were able to vibrate
via the gravitational wave influence if
if then that is what we would kind of
if there is one distinction okay if i
may
that it's not a transverse wave exactly
okay
so sound waves are transverse waves so
the oscillation is along the direction
of propagation
gravitational waves and electromagnetic
waves oscillate perpendicular to the
direction of propagation
okay and that kind of has it's important
for how
it affects our physiology yeah exactly
if we go back to the image up there uh
the oscillation that we measure how
the mirrors at the end of that l-shape
telescope
are being displaced are basically
recorded by the scribble
we can see at the bottom of each banana
the two
graphs are what we measured at the two
different detectors
hanford in washington livingston in
louisiana
so we had the signal was detected
independently in the two detectors at
the same time with only a slight time
delay as i said
and what you see in the signal the real
data
is the scribble so we see that the
oscillation of the mirrors increased
as time progressed the duration
the axis under that scribble is not
shown but the duration is those 0.2
seconds
the amplitude went up as you can see
and then it went down and pittered off
that's when the two black holes came
together
formed a stable black hole and then
there were no more gravitational waves
all right so that's one thing the
amplitude went up the sound you hear
becomes
louder before it dies off the la
the second thing is that the peaks of
each oscillation
come closer and closer together that
means the
frequency of the oscillation is
increasing
and that's the pitch of the sound is
becoming higher and higher
so that's the chirp so that's what we
call a gravitational wave chirp
the banana you see is another way of
representing the exact same phenomenon
the banana gets brighter that's the
amplitude of the
stretching becomes stronger and stronger
and
the frequency goes up as a function of
time
and that's how you get that curvature
and the closer the two black holes are
coming together
the faster the frequency goes up until
it dies off because you form the single
black hole right
all right now now i'm gonna finish by
coming back to your initial question
what we measure is the amplitude of the
wave
the frequency of the wave and the fact
that that frequency of the gravitational
wave
is changing as a function of time
so we're measuring a frequency
derivative
these three pieces of information are
encoding
the masses of the two black holes and
how far away this system was
so that's how by studying that
progression that scribble as i call it
and comparing it
to templates we have from einstein's
theory
so tell us about tell us about those
what are the templates
if we take uh if we take einstein's
theory of general relativity
and uh ask ourselves if two black holes
are at some distance
and we follow space-time and we
solve with general relativity equations
the change in space time as the two
black holes are
moving as the egg beater is messing up
space time around them we can calculate
what is the amplitude the frequency and
the frequency evolution
with time of the gravitational waves
being produced
calculated with computers so
supercomputers in fact because this
calculation this simulation is very very
hard to have to do and you need super
computers to do it and some of these
simulations may run even for months at
the time
so but but we have we the royal we this
is actually not my own personal
work but relativities have been able to
do these simulations for about a little
over 10 years now
so we can create templates of these
kinds of signals
and when we correlate them with our data
from the detector
we can then find the best fitting
template that then
tells us that that particular signal
came from a pair of black holes that is
that far away
and the masses in this particular case
was about 20 or 30 solar masses
uh plus or minus of course there's
always errors in
every measurement we make so that that
was uh
25 20 2016.
so there have been discoveries since can
you give us a sense of
what's been going on the last couple
years yes so since the
that first one that shook our world and
and honestly it shook
it shook humanity if i may say because
we
on that day of the announcement we were
media people at all the universities did
the count not ourselves
but on that one day we were on front
covers more than 900
newspaper front covers across the whole
world now we have announced
another five or so more collisions of
black holes that we have detected in our
data and
another a third gravitational wave
detector in
italy has joined operations so now
there's more confirmation of more of
these events
independent confirmation and now we're
discovering a population
of binary black holes in the universe
now you've also gone beyond black
exactly and that has made again that
sort of the
the second most significant detection
which is
um two neutron stars
quickly tell us what a neutron star oh
yes and we're gonna
we're gonna i'm gonna tell you what the
neutron star is
and and have you all in new york look at
the chicago
skyline since northwestern is in chicago
so um so this is actually this is to
scale
unlike his movie
so this is the chicago skyline um so
a big city you know about 10 miles
across
and the shadow you see hanging above the
chicago skyline
is the edge of a neutron star
to scale now a neutron star is the
death remnant of a star that maybe
10 times the mass of the sun
will end up forming when it runs out of
nuclear fuel
so it will form it will be about um
the the death remnant will be about one
and a half times the mass of the sun
and it will be about as big
as a big city downtown okay
that's roughly the scale you can imagine
how big the circle is
um thankfully no neutron star is hanging
above chicago
as we speak or above new york city uh
but that gives you some sense so
our second biggest discovery which
reached us on august 17
2017 um so we're approaching the
one-year anniversary soon
that was right around the eclipse and
that was that was
another memorable day of course for many
of us um
so it was just a few days before the
eclipse now
it used to be that the big event of that
month was going to be the eclipse and if
this had not happened i would remember
the date
of the eclipse but right now i forgot
the day 21. i think thank you
because what i remember is august 17th
um
so two neutron cells came together in a
similar fashion the
the two neutron stars came together and
we got another banana
except we this time we had three
detectors so you see again hanford
livingstone and we had the italian
detector operating as well
and we saw the two bananas in the two
detectors
the scale you see the signal duration is
much
longer it's no longer just a fraction of
a second
what you see on the screen is about 30
seconds
but actually in our data this is what
you see visually here but in our data we
extracted
the the signal lasted 140 seconds so a
couple of minutes so really
long signal which tells us that the
masses that came together
in this death spiral were actually much
smaller right
so about and one and a half solar mass
as opposed to 30 years
as opposed to 30. so the lower the mass
the longer the signal the longer this
death spiral
lasts now the third detector doesn't
show a banana
uh partly uh because the
third detector is not as sensitive and
partly because
um it was at a very special location on
the sky that the third detector didn't
have good visibility let's say
and then and then spectacular things
happened after
the collision of the two neutron stars
unlike
two black holes which come together in
piece form a single black hole and
nothing else happens after that
two neutron stars actually give us a
whole set of fireworks in
electromagnetic waves
so you could actually not only see them
in gravitational waves you can
see them yes you can see them in light
in real light
and that started a whole other
type of astronomy multi-messenger
astronomy multi-messenger meaning
two types of waves came out of the same
source gravitational waves and
electromagnetic waves and what what have
people learned
from the neutron star collision there's
a lot of talk about
new ways of thinking about nuclear
astrophysics yes so we learned a couple
of different things so first of all
um in the election we learned things up
from this multi-messenger character of
the source so
one thing is that the first thing we saw
in electromagnetic waves was a gamma ray
signal this is the highest frequency
electromagnetic waves we can detect
and we knew gamma ray uh
short bursts of gamma rays existed we
had detected them for many years since
the late 60s
but and we had hypothesized that maybe
mergers of neutron stars were
responsible for them but we had no proof
the proof came from the gravitational
waves
because only in the gravitational waves
we can measure masses
so the measurement that chirp the banana
tells us that it was two neutron stars
that collided
so we've associated with for the first
time we had proof that two neutron cells
collide
can give you a gamma-ray burst burst so
that multi-messenger
uh combination proved the origin of
short gamma-ray bursts
are due to neutron star collisions
that was one big discovery the second
was that the two neutron stars came
together
and as the
[Music]
neutrons collided they actually formed
the
heaviest elements we know on earth so
elements like gold and platinum
a lot heavier than iron we of course
know they exist
we have them uh on our planet we have
them
you know on our rings and earrings or
whatever
uh i lost my wedding ring so i used to
have
one of those does your wife know she
does it's a bit of a sore point but
let's move on okay
so so we know they exist but but
actually astrophysically or physically
we didn't
know for sure how they are formed they
are not formed
in the centers of stars that we knew and
through nuclear reactions so a
hypothesis was
maybe they're formed in neutron star
collisions with this
one event from august 17th we got
experimental proof
through the electromagnetic waves and
gravitational waves telling us two
neutron cells collided
we have now proved that gold was formed
at this one event
and therefore we solve that mystery as
well that's fantastic
congratulations well i i i take credit
not just myself but there is a whole
collaboration of hundreds of scientists
absolutely
so we're we're reaching the end of our
segment but there's one other
question or maybe one and a half
questions so
have you received any data that doesn't
fit the templates or more generally
have how can you imagine testing
einstein's general relativity
in this extreme environment using
gravitational waves we always try to
test einstein
yep okay we pushed that frontier
he made i mean his theory um
must break down at some point
because it involves the singularity at
the center of the black hole and we
don't like centuries
that's what the math just breaks exactly
that's where the division by zero
doesn't make sense so somewhere general
relativity has to break down
with gravitational wave observations
we are observing black holes moving at
half the speed of light 60 percent of
the speed of light this is the strongest
regime of gravity we have ever probed
with anything nothing else has probed
that regime
so so far we have not seen
anything in the gravitational wave data
that disagrees with
general relativity but we keep pushing
that frontier and maybe one day we'll
see something
so it's always at the back of our minds
and and would you say that sort of
would be the culmination of this
enterprise to to
push the understanding of gravity to the
next place the physicists in me
might say that so that's always
something we try to keep testing the
theory
the astrophysicist in me wants to know
about
these black holes and neutron stars how
do they form what's their masses
how can nature form these pairs of black
holes and neutron stars in such high
numbers that we see so many of them
right so this is what we're after on the
astrophysics side
well good luck with all those
fantastically interesting projects and
everybody please join me in thanking
vicky
thank you thank you
[Music]